c'est l'appareil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
lorsque j'ai tourné la vidéo est ce que
j'ai publié tout cas ma vidéo parce que
j'avais fait c'est déjà un petit moment
ou non j'ai tout remballer dans le
studio effectivement je vous disais
c'est la fin c'est la fin de quelque
chose très clairement c'est l appareil
c'est le cas alors je vous ai pas tout
dit il ya des choses que je vous ai pas
dit je vous explique ma société est
basée à paris tout le temps des
placements paris parce que paris c'est
le centre névralgique de la france
puisque la joueuse après absolument rien
c'est là où tout se passe en tout cas au
terme de presse d'évènements tout est à
paris mais moi j'habite à paris
moi j'habite au centre de la france
j'habite à clermont ferrand et le studio
est basé à clermont ferrand
sauf qu'aujourd'hui pour le
fonctionnement de la chaîne et pour mon
travail à moi c'est plus possible
d'abord le studio ici à clermont ferrand
les choses changent
c'est la fin c'est la fin du studio ici
à clermont ferrand
direction maintenant paris j'ai pris des
studios à paris donc ça c'est
l'excellente nouvelle et c'est en ça
justement c'est la fin c'est la fin des
studios ici enfin c'est pas exactement
la fin parce que pour l'instant la
famille reste à clermont ferrand je suis
beaucoup à paris beaucoup notamment pour
le travail donc je suis partagé en deux
il yad'un côté clairement et le studio
qui va rester ici taclé en version lite
n'ont pas de tombe beaucoup de vidéos et
6 mai m'arrivera lorsque je vois
présents ici de portrait des vidéos et
scanner photon premiers décors version
lite cet endroit un petit peu light et
tout le reste sera tourné à paris de
leur côté dans le nouveau studio nouveau
départ nouveau lieu on est beaucoup plus
loin à quelques grosse centaine de
kilomètres du studio d pas aller dans
tout nouveau studio et on va commencer
une nouvelle aventure alors l'aider je
vous montre un petit peu comment savoir
si j'avais vraiment hâte de pouvoir vous
montrer un peu ce nouveau studio vous
montrer comment ça allait pouvoir se
passer c'est autre chose
vous pouvez voir là pour le coup on a
vraiment poussé les murs regardez je
vous montre un petit peu regardez bien
la dernière
sauf la cgt cela plus en détail et puis
y'a plein de nouveautés sur la chine
surtout à des mois soit peu la tête par
là par la pala par la perla par la perla
par la perla la voilà parle parle parle
parle parle pas là c'est grand très
grand
nouveau studio spacieux on va faire
plein de nouvelles sur cette année la
toute première chose ça va être des
podcasts on va faire du podcast audio à
ça s'arrête grosse nouveauté cette année
c'est pas si vous avez déjà lu j'ai déjà
tourné un petit peu ici dans ce coin on
a
du matos sm7 deux jours il ya des castro
mystère de la radio à quelque chose près
à donc de se faire du podcast moi j'ai
fait de la radio pendant très longtemps
j'avais vraiment envie de pouvoir
recommencer partir sur une nouvelle base
et la super content parce que regarder
l'âge et où le corner tort aux castes
qu'il est ici avec les deux micros il y
aura mois et un invité quasiment à
chaque fois c'est en train de s'écrire
un ça va c'est un très très très
rapidement donc vous invite à vous
inscrire comme ça vous saurez plus où
mettre et où la déception on en
reparlera vraiment certain de type reip
raku donc là j'ai tout mon matos coûté
podcast côté un peu ici pour venir
bosser on l'était la ya quelques
instants c'est justement de là où je
pars allait regarder l'autre côté là où
il ya tout le matos que j'ai ramené que
jerry d'un ancien studio qui n était pas
ici avec une une fenêtre pour prendre un
peu les lumières naturelles ça sera du
bien ici là c'est le corner où je fais
les reviews d'ailleurs que j'accroche la
caméra ici je m'étais pas nos lettres de
chaque côté mais bursa pour l'instant
c'est pas bien grave
pour l'instant le pain de l'aide il est
situé juste en face et vous avez son
petit frère qui est au fond de notre
côté donc ici le côté review avec une
petite accroche manfrotto un pied girafe
lester en bas donc on va se faire tout
les reviews hier ça va venir un ça va
être décoré parce que pour l'instant il
n'y a pas grand chose
vous voyez ici là donc à sa fin un grand
corner avec ici un joli tableau pour
prendre des notes si je veux et si on a
un grand mur qu'on va venir accueillir
le mans a fait un truc avec je vous le
dis pas tout si je vous dirais plutôt
grâce à une grosse déco surtout ce mur
la salette idrac cool et lorsqu'on suis
bon ça je vous l'avais montré la celle
le côté effectivement podcast donc ça si
je suis super content c'était vraiment
très très longtemps je voulais faire ça
alors vous voyez il y aurait un peu de
bazar
j'ai ramené le bazar d'un côté je les ai
mis de côté et là on arrive dans le côté
je dire un peu plus
c'est encore vraiment vraiment vraiment
en installation et si le côté un peu
plus ce salon test de télé il ya cette
télé là que pour vous ai déjà parlé
c'est la nano celle de lg c'est la 4k en
139 cm et 55 pouces il y en a une autre
que j'ai testé très bientôt qui est
juste plantés ici c'est une télé de
philips là pour vous voyez encore un
tous les cartons ça ça va ça va changer
notre hôte qui est juste là en février
ça fait quand même un studio qui est
vachement grands il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de choses alors on verra
voilà il ya plein de choses à mettre en
place est ici comme je vous disais le
côté salon là derrière je veux mettre à
un espèce de grands cadres grand tableau
affiches posters je sais pas quoi on
verra donc la silk way cool relax
peut-être qu'il y aura des invités
peut-être peut-être pas je sais pas
plein de choses qui vont se mettre en
place
voyager encore en train de meubler
apprend à détacher la caméra on en est
vraiment qu'au début la voyez par
exemple j'ai deux chaises qui m'ont été
envoyés par rect qui vont servir et qui
vont venir s'installer juste là pour
remplacer ses chaises là elle elle va
partir ici au bureau principal là une
fois que j'aurai ranger tout ça je veux
mettre un très grand écran très grand
bon état pour pouvoir bosser je vais
installer mon as très bientôt ici je
vais installer ma bbox quelque part par
ici avec la fibre en février va y avoir
plein plein plein de choses qui vont se
mettre en place
l'idée c'est donc d'apporter de la
nouveauté alors on va toujours rester
sur ce qu'on avait fait jusqu'à présent
c'est à dire des tests et des
orientations de smartphones beaucoup
d'actu fin tout ça on va continuer ça
n'a absolument pas changé mais on va
enrichir tout ça est apporté plein de
nouvelles choses déjà en terme de
contenu principal donc il va y avoir les
podcasts saas avec de l'audio pour
retrouver sur toutes les plateformes
spotify apple music company mais ça je
vous le dirai très bientôt
on en reparlera le temps tous à se
mettre en place le sauver c'est la
rentrée c'est un peu le branle bas de
combat
il ya aussi le bouton rejoindre qui est
mis en place qui est privé est mis en
place sont en train de finaliser moment
sur 13 pour les cette vidéo juste à côté
du bouton s'abonner donc si vous voulez
participer si vous devenir contributeur
si vous êtes devenir un membre à part
entière de la communauté et participer
au financement
de la chaîne et bien vous avez le bouton
rejoindre avec en face des contributions
qui sont mises en place selon les
différents paliers ça vous allez pouvoir
le voir si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
on fera aussi des live ça se met en
place un tremblement d'encours en
octobre une fois par semaine
normalement le dimanche on ferait un là
il faut pouvoir parler pour que je
puisse vous parlez vous présenter des
produits qui peut être pas le temps de
vous montrer cette manière là pouvoir
faire des discussions répondre à vos
questions et justement pour répondre à
vos questions
je fais un truc qui a passé une fois de
plus en train de se mettre en place tout
ça en train de s'imbriquer voyez c'est
un forum j'aurais pu le faire sur
discorde mais j'ai préféré le faire
directement sur mon nom de domaine avant
le forum monsieur l'idée c'est quoi
l'idée c'est que vous avez un forum sur
lequel vous venez vous vous inscrivez de
pouvoir parler à la communauté je serai
présent pour vous répondre
n'est pas que moi il y aura aussi les
membres de la communauté qui seront là
et qu'ils vont jouer un rôle important
le constat c'est que je peux pas
répondre à tout le monde dans les
commentaires et je sais c'est compliqué
je voudrais le faire mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas toujours
toujours hyper simple mais par contre
c'est que parmi vous il ya beaucoup
d'experts beaucoup de personnes qui
avaient des connaissances souvent assez
pointu pas sur tous les modèles pas sur
tous les smartphones passant tous les
ordis toutes les tablettes mais sûrement
beaucoup de produits et justement l'idée
c'est de pouvoir réunir un peu tout le
monde au même endroit pour pouvoir
s'entraider c'est plus un forum
d'entr'aide donc regarder forum par
marque et vous allez pouvoir venir si
vous êtes plus vous faites par exemple
je sais pas de symptômes de chimie
d'apple ou que sais-je de web de la
marque que vous souhaitez vous pouvez
l'histoire de cette partie là aider les
autres venir poser vos questions il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui sont en phase
d'achat et de pose pas je suis là je
voudrais lâcheté comment vous trouvez
par rapport à celui là lequel vous
paraître le lieu qu'est ce que vous
pensez par rapport à cette marque l'an
face et justement vous allez pouvoir
venir trouver des solutions vous allez
pouvoir et des jeux mais aussi être là
derrière pour cet intrus qui va être
vachement cool donc ça c'est pareil ça
va être super et je compte sur vous pour
le faire vivre
je vais également mettre en place toute
une partie de questions-réponses une faq
l'idée c'est effectivement du dia
maintien on va prendre une vidéo
peut-être toutes les semaines peut-être
tous les dix jours à voir en fonction de
vos questions console d'actualité qui
prend le temps de vous répondre tout
simplement travers d'une vidéo dédiée
l'idée c'est que dans les commentaires
vous posez vos questions
et moi je vous réponds dans peut-être
que je créerai une partie spéciale sur
le forum je sais pas que je suis pas sûr
on verra quelle manière on fera venir me
poser vos questions sur twitter vous
taguée monsieur groupe pour je vois les
questions je puisse en prendre note
directement bas dans les commentaires
comme ça on se fera une faq dédiée
ça pourrait être cool hawks point
répondre à vos questions au travers des
live au travers des faq et pour toutes
les questions le reste vous viendrez sur
le forum comme ça on va pouvoir parler
ensemble
voilà un peu pour les grandes lignes de
cette rentrée donc de dire toujours
toujours toujours plein de choses jours
pleins de tech va y avoir beaucoup de
lancements on va aller parler des
grosses nouveautés des nouveautés de
smartphones je vais aussi prendre le
temps de la chercher peut-être des
sujets un peu plus de fond vous
emmènerez toujours avec moi en voyage à
l'égard des trucs hyper cool de prévu et
croyez moi j'ai hyper à parce que on va
aller se balader dans le monde entier
une fois de plus ça va être vraiment
vraiment cool aura donc de la tech des
tests de l' aventure plus de place pour
la communauté pour pouvoir échanger
regarde tout ça c'est top je suis très
content que pour partager avec vous
c'était effectivement la fin de quelque
chose la fin du studio clermont mais
croyez moi on va continuer à y mettre
encore un peu les pieds parce que je
peux pas être ici j'ai ma famille bien
évidemment clamons et ça c'est génial
donc on retrouvera un peu l'ancien décor
on sera beaucoup pisi et je compte sur
vous pour m'aider me dire bah tiens on
pourrait mettre ça qu'est ce que tu
penses de remettre ça pour décorer si tu
pourrais faire si vous avez des idées
pour les marques et embarquant
commentaires je suis preneur merci à
vous d'être présent présente de répondre
à l'appel
faut dire gros bisous et à demain